even a few years after the conclusions
of all-time classic shows such as Mad
Men Breaking Bad and Parks and
Recreation we're still in the second
Golden Age of TV also known as peak TV
also known as there is far too much good
stuff to watch on broadcast television
cable and at least four streaming
services there's just so much to watch
Game of Thrones Westworld The Walking
Dead Atlanta Silicon Valley still
despite all this come miss TV there are
plenty of other series you can go ahead
and skip the following got our picks for
the very worst shows of 2018 so far Alex
Inc ABC promoted Alex Sink is a
triumphant return of Zach Braff away
from TV for almost a decade after scrubs
finished its nine season run this is
partly a typical family comedy about a
goofy dad his long-suffering wife and
their kids but it's also about a guy who
was a midlife crisis stars his own
company and documents that journey
through podcasting based on the true
story of start-up host Alex Blumberg
Alex Inc reveals to audiences that not
very visually entertaining world of
people talking into microphones while
podcasts a mainstream at this point the
show treats a concept like it's
cutting-edge technology and people treat
Alex like he's a genius for making one
simply unbelievable I hate to disagree
with you I hated enough to make to fit
child supports Ricky Gervais for the TV
legends for co-creating and starring in
the original British office as well as a
show business satire extras and the
nursing home drama D Derek but his
latest project isn't a single-camera
comedy or nuance character study instead
child support as one part kids say the
darndest things
one part overly convoluted game show in
a TV studio host Fred Savage asks adult
contestants trivia questions if they
answer correctly their responses are
compared to the answers given by a panel
of adorable children to face us the kids
the same questions and a creepy-looking
focus group it's more unusual than
amusing and that's a laughing place as
noted the questions are painfully easy
and the show tries too hard to be funny
Benjamin Franklin said early to bed and
early to rise makes a man healthy
wealthy and what
deception the early two-thousands are
over but that IRA's biggest contribution
to television and jaws the crime
procedural with a sassy twist the likes
of bones Castle and The Mentalist are
all gone but they continue in spirit
with ABC's deception it's about a
celebrity magician with the very
celebrity magician name of Cameron black
after his career was destroyed by a
scandal he teams up with the FBI to
solve crimes that's right he uses his
gift for illusions to somehow get into
the minds of criminals which is a pretty
weak premise but winning over viewers as
one magic trick Cameron has not managed
to pull off a ten meaningless supporting
characters and what's been described by
variety as a fatal lack of surprises and
there's not much left to watch
life-sentence
the pre Z CW drama D life sentence
officer basically the same setup as a
2001 Disney movie Mac's keyboards big
move but in this case it's about a young
woman named Stella who thought she was
dying of cancer for years she lived
every day like it was a last only to
have a cancer cure leaving her to deal
with the ramifications of her impulsive
decisions there's a decent premise here
but the execution just feels too cruel
to its main character while leaving
other moments overly sentimental
ultimately it's just an even mix living
biblically based on humorist AJ Jacobs
book the year of living biblically this
CBS sitcom is about a critic who decides
to live out every last detail of his
life according to the Holy Bible more
dots or if fillable premise is difficult
to make religion funny and palatable to
a broad audience secular audiences are
alienated more the show also skirts
offending the faithful never really
finding an audience ultimately living
biblically commits the Cardinal comedy
sin of just not being very funny the
resident Matt sue Cree stars has dr.
Conrad Hawkins a medical rogue who plays
by his own rules dr. Hawkins makes rash
decisions and ignores directives from
his superiors because he has gut
feelings about what crazy medical
procedures to use except he doesn't come
across as heroic just arrogant and
smarmy instead he's just another
antihero who thinks he can get away with
anything like we've seen so many times
before and that is a residence biggest
flaw it doesn't offer anything new to
the TV landscape sweet bitter this star
series follows naive Tess who leaves her
hometown behind to move to the
or New York is unexpectedly tough until
test has taken under the wing of
colleagues at the fancy restaurant when
she finds work almost immediately she
reminds them of themselves only younger
and more optimistic accept cliches are a
big problem on sweet bitter a very
slow-moving show where nothing much
happens beyond the woman working in a
restaurant for making friends Robert
Lloyd at the Los Angeles Times quarter a
meal that looks great on the plate but
makes little impression on the tongue
splitting up together this ABC Family
sitcom is at least an innovative if not
vaguely depressing twist on an old
format mom and dad are in the process of
divorcing but rather than have one of
them move foul to both parents stay in
the house keeping separate living
quarters so as to still provide their
kids with an uninterrupted and stable
home life while that's a modern and
progressive solution it's a hard sell
for a silly little sitcom and the
calling to the Orlando Sentinel it feels
like a long force push to get the Maine
couple back together here and now set in
the progressive city of Portland Oregon
here and now is about a progressive
family made up of a philosophy professor
his therapist wife and therefore mostly
grown children adopted from around the
world their one biological child is in
High School where she encounters many
didactic conversations about social
issues offset by weird dreams and
prophetic hallucinations basically
imagine if Portlandia wasn't accommoda
but was instead just as serious and
ominous as the leftovers according to
Joel color of decider here and now is so
overwrought that it makes a ham maids
tale it like a light-hearted romp by
comparison dark